il faut une machine tu
[Musique]
société le 30 juillet dernier la nasa
qui lançait le robot persévérance vers
la planète mars est bien va se poser
dans quelques jours pour tenter de
trouver d'anciennes traces de vie et une
canadienne fait partie de l'équipe de
pilotage qui sera aux commandes du robot
farah ali b originaire de joliette qui
est ingénieur en aérospatiale pour la
nasa
on la retrouve en direct de la
californie bonjour farah bonjour faire
que j'ai connu il ya 25 ans âgés de 6 et
7 ans qui patinent et au klube rouges et
aimant une prise spécifique royal de
voir votre parcours fera vous devez
avoir des papillons dans le ventre de
voir là le robot qui va se poser jeudi
sur la planète mars
oh oui j'en ai même en ce moment ça a
été difficile de me lever ce matin pour
promener vous parler même si et 6 heures
du matin ça doit plus trop bien mais
reste plus quelques jours par an
commenté salah beaucoup de fébrilité
beaucoup de travail derrière ça oh oui
énormément les six derniers mois vous
demandez maman s'appelle si j'avais tort
de l'appeler pour tout et bonjour la fin
de semaine
à chaque fois que ma pêche au travail
l'on prend en fait quelques jours de
congé pour se reposer avant d'atterrir
parce que le travail commence aussitôt
qu'on touche la surface hummer donc là
avant de parler de votre rôle spécifique
qui est vraiment passionnant dites-moi
leur rappeler moi c'est quoi la mission
donc de persévérance bon c'est de
vérifier s'il ya vraiment déjà eu de la
vie sur mars ici oui c'est seulement que
persévérance va en payer dans le delta
d'une ancienne rivière en fait c'est un
acquis maintenant sec et on va étudier
la géologie va voir ce qui s'est passé
dans cet état là parce que ce soit on
cherche pour deux l'astrobiologie on
cherche pour des signes d'anciennes
d'anciennes vie parce qu'on pense qu'il
ya des millions d'années mars aurait pu
ressembler à la terre et dans son antre
matin il y avait de la vie micro bien
donc on pense que peut-être que sur
marseille aurait pu avoir un avis donc
on va poser la question en fait est ce
qu'on est tout seul est ce que j'ai pu
et d'un avis sur une planète
ah oui et puis là vous comptez aussi
rapporter des échantillons de la planète
mars dans les bagages là avec leur ai
dit exactement donc
le robot peut prendre des échantillons
on va voyager sur 10 ans dans différents
endroits sur la surface de masse on va
prendre des échantillons et les laisser
sur mars et le but c'est qu'on a enduré
une autre mission pour aller chercher
les échantillons et les rennais
manhattan on confond on avait une autre
petite fusée sur mars pour aller les
chercher les ramener vers la terre dans
une dizaine d'années un peuple bon et
dites moi ça va être quoi votre rôle
exactement je disais à mes enfants il ya
c'est un peu comme quand vous jouez avec
une auto téléguidée mais là c'est un
robot téléguidé sur la planète mars
ça peut faire c'est à peu près ça m'a un
peu compliqué donc c'est ça je vais pas
partie de l'équipe qui va faire les
opérations du robot et aussi de
l'hélicoptère qu'on amène avec nous on a
un petit hélicoptère ont offert une
démonstration technologie du vol sur
mars et je fais partie de l'équipe qui
fait les opérations mais quand on fait
des opérations somers et pas téléguidé
parce que pour que nos signaux se rendre
20 mars
en fait ça va à la vitesse de la lumière
mais c'est tellement loin que ça prend
entre douze et quinze minutes pour le
signal de se rendre en mars bien de mise
pour que ça revenait donc ce serait
vraiment long avec si on fait se sentent
eu l'idée de dire ok avant ce jeu 30
minutes plus tard qui reçoit les données
qu'ils avancent dans ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on programme tout à l'avance tout est
automatisé
donc à chaque nuit martienne avec mon
équipe on fait on prépare les commandes
pour le robot et pendant la journée le
robot fait ses activités prend des
photos prendre et donner nous envoie
tout ça en après midi
on veut les analyses et on recommence
forcément quand on new as well as la
nuit sous marin oui c'est ça c'est assez
passionnant la nuit martienne séquence à
la nuit martienne mais ça n'est pas en
fait parce que une journée merci d'une
journée complète martienne
ces 24 heures et 40 minutes donc quand
on atterrit le décalage horaire
entre los angeles où je suis et où
persévérance va gérer ça va être à peu
près trois heures donc 18h sommer ça va
être à peu près 15 heures sur terre ok
moi je commence à 18h à chaque jour
mais comme la journée est un petit peu
plus longue sur mars
ça veut dire que j'ai commencé à 15
heures jeudi après 15 ans 40 14
donc à chaque jour ma journée se décale
de 2,42 à oui c'est ça donc vraiment un
horaire différent un peu chaque jour et
comment vous allez faire pour ne pas le
perdre de vue ce robot là comment vous
allez faire pour vous orienter sur cette
planète l'ain ont fait plusieurs choses
quand on va atterrir on va voir des
photos et des vidéos de l'atterrissage
donc on veut savoir exactement où est ce
que le robot et sur mars et apprécié
sommes en fait c'est une partie de ma
job c'est de mettre ce que l'eurostar a
peur on utilise des instruments qu'on a
à bord et on utilise aussi le soleil
pour s'orienter donc comme nos premiers
explorer qui est utilisé les étoiles
pour se retrouver ou les toits du nord
pour savoir comment se retrouver sur
mars les robots issus de soleil et lors
de la journée pour savoir dans quelle
direction on est orienté et comment
parler à la terre
ouah alors c'est pas votre première
mission avec la nasa mais c'est celle
qui est la plus importante j'imagine oui
c'est là j'ai travaillé sur notre
mission que ça fait une scène qui
atterrissent sur mars il ya deux ans je
peux vous dire que ça ne restez pas plus
fertiles la deuxième fois mais cette
fois ci en plus ne vaut beaucoup plus
gros beaucoup plus complexe et on va
conduire cette fois ci sont merci de la
grosseur d'une voiture environ les
robots oui c'est à peupler comme une
mini cooper est un peu plus élevé et ça
ça va ça pèse environ une tonne hockey
et la phase critique
on va y assister jeudi c'est vraiment
l'atterrissage si je peux dire là au
moment où le robot va se poser sur mars
et là où où ça peut être compliqué oui
je dis toujours pour l'atterrissage
il faut qu'on aimerait aa parce qu'un
bep plus si on n'y arrive pas sur mars
donc c'est vraiment ces sept minutes qui
sont très très complexe tout est
automatisé
parce que justement comme je
l'expliquais on est trop loin pour faire
ça en dirait oui et donc s'ils arrivent
c'est que du moment qu'on rentre dans
l'atmosphère qu'on voit des centaines de
mètres par rapport par seconde
il faut qu'on atterrisse tout doucement
sur la surface de mars et 11 7 minutes
pour faire ça c'est une danse très
compliqué et ça nous fait c'est pour ça
qu'on extrait 6 parce que lyon s'est pas
toujours on réussit pas tout le temps
c'est un moment le plus difficile de la
mission eh bien on va être avec vous en
direct pour suivre ça c'est clair
donc je dis on parle beaucoup à farah
des femmes cette semaine en sciences
avec la journée internationale des
femmes et des filles en sciences qui
avait lieu jeudi
c'est vraiment passionnant votre
parcours de joliette jusqu'à la nasa
avec cette mission est vraiment
impressionnante alors bravo merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sitôt
pour vous un décalage horaire et bonne
mission merci beaucoup merci on va voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit